why are you broken number how was tough
and edgy yeah remember how I was just
like you yeah I was tough and edgy why
do you have tea and Swedish butter
cookies I don't know what you people
like why are you my fault there can't be
two Riley's just like there can't be two
Mayas for the world to work there needs
to be one Riley and one Maya I know that
language that's Topanga knees she's
right is she what happens when you meet
a good influence and they just start to
change you for the better that's when
your art teacher says you're incomplete
yeah tell me about it
I know because I had a good influence
you're incomplete
look you know when your dad and I first
met all he wanted was to be like me
you don't think I'm a geek firstly you
think I'm cool of course not you're Cory
I'm Shawn just like it's always been
what else do you need to know it was
ridiculous that he wanted to be like me
I mean the guy had a great family yeah
he had parents who were there yeah and
then Cory met Topanga do you know what
it's like to go to high school with
Romeo and Juliet
you